okay i was hoping you had this this is
hilarious go ahead yeah go ahead well
you mentioned this so i finally spoke up
about why he didn't put the belt on
francis he said he was dealing with
stuff backstage uh-huh yeah and my
theory on this okay so this is what dana
said
so uh during a fan q a session on svm
plus wednesday
he was i wasn't out there for the main
event i actually walked out of the arena
right after the co-main event because
there was stuff going on backstage i was
dealing with
but it doesn't say what he's dealing
with right for anybody to think that i
was showing any type of disrupt towards
francis you were i saw friends all week
you idiots i shook his hand i said hi to
him i was out there for the stare downs
the whole thing you weren't there for
the most important thing though dana for
anybody to think there was some type of
disrespect shown towards france i was
out there for michael bisping versus
rockhold he's like see i've done it
before
um because i was doing some stuff this i
spent from the back i didn't even have
my jacket i only had my shirt on to go
out there put the belt on bisping but i
couldn't make it out there to put the
belt on francis the only been one time i
walked out of fight and i made it very
clear show up to the press conference
said this exactly where i left i was an
abbey dog with amy silva it was the
damien my fight so there's the answer i
don't know if somebody asked that but
somebody wanted to there you go uh it
was an absolute honor receiving the belt
from
mcmanyard uh france wrote can be a
better person i love this man for sure
bro i don't care about that i'm happy
that's all that matters yeah i'm with
francis on this here's the thing with
dana so
what i think happened is um
you know there's some stuff that went on
before the week of the fight there's
some stuff that went on between
uh dana and francis representation and
clearly
anytime a fighter especially a france
magnitude fights back in cfc he's very
uh
out about it it creates um animosity for
dana and the fighter so it's awkward
it's awkward for him it's awkward for
his representation the ufc hates
france's reputation because they don't
play the same game everybody else is
because everybody else for the most part
are sheeps because wm wme represents the
ufc dana white right they
it's a conflict of interest to the
fullest extent so they hate that francis
isn't going uh when they say jump he's
asking how high he's when the only
outliers you ask all right how high i'll
jump but how high do i need to jump
so i think this animosity led up to the
fight
and they were banking and also the ufc
brass dana especially knew that francis
had one leg going this fight
he was not expected to win this fight
so they thought they had him dead to
rights they thought this was over this
will make all this go away france can be
forced to sign with us
you don't know francis ingano you don't
know that this ain't [ __ ] compared to
what he's dealt with his entire life
mentally you have no idea how strong
francis is he figures out how to get
done even on one leg wins
and it it and it puts all the chips in
france's corner all the chips
it's dana's ego it's dana's ego that
it's his one downfall man it just
this one downfall and i said this last
week on the show i said it's the francis
on food truck or maybe the classified
companion
i can't believe he doesn't have someone
around his team
that when this was going on when france
is going to win the fight and dana had
to sprint to the back to deal with
issues during the biggest moment of the
night
and issues they don't tell us about
right
there could have been a bigger issue
than putting a belt on francis
everybody in that arena knows what it
will look like if dana doesn't put the
belt on francis right
i can't believe there's not someone in
his circle whether it's a co-worker an
assistant
a colleague a peer that goes hey man
you've won but you've won dude you've
won you have 500 million in the bank all
you got to do let's not create this
narrative it's going to make you look
really bad it is so make you look bad if
you don't put the belt on france you
look like a sore loser
put the belt on them let's be
professional and then we'll deal with
the x's and o's and the numbers after
the fact but he's deserved this he
deserves this and all this does is give
him more power in negotiations the way
you're treating him it's not a good look
man just be cool also you've won you
have 500 million the bank dude francis
says nothing
i know you're paying 650 000 after taxes
paying the traders it's nothing for him
let's not let's not stir the pot man
you've won and also remember just go put
the belt on them because then there's no
story here it helps us in negotiations
after this and also remember you have
500 million dollars in the bank dude
right you have 500 million to make your
your
kids kids kids kids kids you got
generational wealth francis does not
france can't take
two years off and continue to live a
good life he has to fight he's a cage
fighter
you remember dana i'd whisper into
remember dude she put the belt on him so
it doesn't create all this chaos and
make you look like an [ __ ] and puts
more people in france's corner put the
belt on and remember dude you have 500
million the bank you've won and we still
jump on your private jet what house you
want to go to dude you want to go to
your miami house we're going to the
vegas house you want to go to the
newport house
montana new york we have all we go to
brazil your house there what do you want
to do dude you've won there's no reason
to act like this
but
part of the reason what makes dana white
great is also his biggest liability and
that's his ego and the ego got the best
of them and he was a sore loser no i'm
not doing this and then ran to the back
okay cool
well
there's one person that can control dana
white there's one person his name's arya
manuel he's the owner of wme and when he
says jump he's the only guy on the
planet dana goes how high sir he's the
only guy
i'm willing to bet
that somebody in that powerful circle
when that got done called and went what
the [ __ ] are you doing what are you
doing
what are you doing are you out of your
mind we're in negotiation with this guy
this is the one guy
that might make a change for the
fighters do you realize what you're
doing and you're just adding fuel to the
[ __ ] fireman and why
because he bet on himself when he won on
one [ __ ] leg are you out of your mind
you're gonna make this right
the next time somebody asks you about
this you better come up with something
where you don't look like complete
[ __ ]
and what happened
oh no i love francis i actually i was
dealing with something in the back it's
happened before
and uh no i mean france was cool all
week i was at the stare down
okay okay
i guarantee you
the guys that call the shots now the ufc
sold
ain't they're not playing that game
you're adding more fuel to the [ __ ]
fire
you're not helping this thing out this
does not help negotiations
and they've done everything if you look
at they've done everything i've talked
off camera with people on france's team
they've done everything in their power
to try and take the power away from
francis and ghana they can't stand that
this man has the power over them they
can't stand he's the face of the
heavyweight division
they can't stand that he banked himself
with one leg and he shouldn't be here
and he still [ __ ] won they can't
stand
that now he's taught now he's getting
even bigger he's getting me even louder
they can't stand it he's
represented by ca they hate that but
he's continue
they don't realize what i'm telling you
man they don't realize what they're
dealing with you're talking about a
complete [ __ ] outlier with the mental
strength of a [ __ ] special forces
soldier that's gone through [ __ ] that
you can't even imagine dana you can't
even [ __ ] fathom who you're [ __ ]
with
oh on top of that mental strength
he has the body of a [ __ ] x-men and
he's the hardest hitter to ever walk
through that god damn cage
and you wanna you think you're gonna
break that guy you think you can
disrespect that guy not put the belt on
him are you out of your goddamn mind
and this isn't a [ __ ] on dana episode at
all i'm a fan i don't think the ufc
would have got where they've where
they've gotten without dana's vision his
work ethic his ego
again that ego is his biggest
biggest
biggest achilles heel on him it's
troubleman
but what happened i told i [ __ ] told
you guys so that our emanuel went what
are you doing dude you've just given
them even more [ __ ] fuel by not
putting the bell on and why
what are you doing
now we're seeing it oh no no no i didn't
disrespect them i i had to you you could
so you had to write something was so
important hey you can't tell us
something was so important you have to
rush to the back
you're not helping francis
look at the star power on that card
let's talk about that what about the
star power on that card was it the was
it a stack card for you guys
was there not complaints about the card
oh well we put the flyweight
championship on there you know the
flyweights don't bring massive views
so let's talk about that why would you
put
and descend disrespecting the fighters
on them i'm just talking about it's very
black and white why was the rest of the
car no star power
anyone know why
well in negotiations
what they're going to do with france is
i put this sold
between three to four hundred thousand
pay-per-views
which isn't bad they need 300k to which
they think uh to get their nut back
right
so and you look at the pay structures
they made all the money in the world
that this card there's no star power on
it so
by stacking
a card you're you you can't really
figure out who
you can credit the main event because
they were the main event that's who we
put on the marketing bill and that's the
headliners and they get a pay-per-view
point and they're going to make more
money
sure but when the card's not when you
look at ufc 100 ufc 200 you look at some
of these
pay-per-views coming up they're all more
stacked than this one
that was a complete strategic business
move by the ufc and the brass of the ufc
to undermine francis and ganu because
it's francis the biggest name in america
as far as pay-per-view goes no he's been
out for a while cyril gone not his star
yet he's just not a star yet
so they put flyweights on there so they
don't draw too much attention to it they
look at the rest of the card
i don't think any of those guys have
ever really no one else has ever been a
headliner no one else is really a star
pay-per-view driven fighter
they do that so now
when ca sits down with wme and
negotiates a deal for francis what's
fair then go
last fight only did 300 000 man
it's not great
you don't deserve the whatever money
you're asking for it's not an obscene
amount of money it's what's right if he
if he asks for what's
exactly what he's due it'd be an obscene
amount of money but we can't even play
that game he's trying to get somewhat
higher
so there's a reason why that
pay-per-view as far as um
pay-per-view star power
it wasn't on there because now it's
again it's another thing
to go against francis ingano it's a
[ __ ] shame
it's a [ __ ] shame because remember
too
that
you know him give pay-per-view points it
lowers everything and you see
they don't care if they sell
200 300 000 more pay views on this one
or the next one or the next one or the
next one they're gonna get theirs the
house always wins
and that's why i tell you guys
i don't need you to be a franciscano fan
maybe you don't like something that he
does or maybe you don't like this or
that i don't care about any of that
i told you go on this fight even if
you're [ __ ] from france and you went
to a [ __ ] middle school cyril gone if
they have middle school and french i
don't know how it works out there but
even if that's your if you if that was
your [ __ ] neighbor you should root
for francis in this fight sarah will be
champion eventually
but right now what francis is doing has
never been done before and he can change
the game for everybody on that roster
it's historic man i can't emphasize that
enough you want this guy to win
you've all had shitty bosses out there
we've all worked for the man it [ __ ]
sucks and now you got a guy i told you
with a special forces [ __ ] mindset in
the body of an x-men
and he's trying to make the change
he's then you need someone of that
magnitude to make the change he's the
only guy
connor ain't the guy anymore
connor set
his path has been set he has too much
money to make the change he's not his
prime anymore that's over khabib's
retired
that's over you have nobody else like
francis you have your heavyweight champ
of the world
talking about where's our health care
where's our fighter pay
and then he beats the guy that they
thought was going to beat him on one
[ __ ] leg
now he's saying
what's up now they've stacked everything
against them they even put the belt
around them
think about it it's clear the writings
on the [ __ ] wall shitty pay-per-view
so he has no negotiating power didn't
put the belt on him made him sit out for
out fought once a year barely
they've done everything in their power
to get this man to lose
but they've never ever dealt with a
[ __ ] animal like francis ingano ever
and his team
shout to markel they've never dealt with
anything
than these two [ __ ] men who have the
vision that they have
and there's a board meeting today with
with the [ __ ] ufc
i just for the life of me i can't figure
out i hope hopefully arya man was in
that [ __ ] meeting because we got to
get dana's ego out of this one
and we need dana we need him on board to
get this deal done he has to he's the
only he has to be on board otherwise the
deal doesn't get done
we gotta [ __ ] ca [ __ ] these camps it's
about francis
and even as a businessman
that the ufc is going to make more money
with franciscano in the ufc and then
helping promote his fights with tyson
fury than any other scenario that
they're going to figure out
how much money would the ufc make if
they can just
give francis not not what he's do
because you're never going to pay that
i'm just saying a higher guarantee
a fraction of what he's worth
and marking him the same way
how much more money are you going to get
doing that and you get the jon jones
super fight you get at least two tyson
fury collabs how much more money you
miss out on all that
but at the end of the day you know who
misses out the most the fans and you owe
it to the fans
you've increased your pay-per-view price
you force this to buy espn plus
what else do you want man you owe it to
us to put your ego to the side on this
one time dana i [ __ ] beg you man put
the ego to the side and figure this out
with france's team and don't look at
francis as ca versus wme look at it as
[ __ ] a guy who runs the best
biggest baddest
fight league in the world to ever do it
and you're probably the greatest
president of all [ __ ] time man you're
up there with roger goodell i'll give
you that credit man you're the [ __ ]
guy
for this one time i beg you man put your
ego to the side and work with francis
team you [ __ ] you [ __ ] owe it to us
the fans otherwise we miss out on
francis jon jones
that's the only fight i want to see i
want to see nothing else i speak for
millions of people dude
you [ __ ] owe it to us you want that
extra money play ball i'll give you
whatever money you want
whatever you're selling i'll [ __ ] buy
whatever you want man
but this one time i need you put your
ego decide and look at him like a
[ __ ] human being and get the deal
done because you owe us francis jon
jones you owe us tyson fury francis you
got to be involved in that why won't you
want to be involved with that
you owe it to us do what's right you've
already won dude you've already won
it doesn't take away from your shine if
you give francis some shine
the only reason we heard his remarkable
story which has been sold to hollywood
his life story has been sold to
hollywood they have seven different
[ __ ] offers from the biggest movie
studios to ever do it
hollywood knows his story the fans are
just getting a story but where did the
story come from
not the ufc even though you guys are the
best in the world at marketing there's
nobody better you're better than the nfl
the nba not even close kudos to you you
have an amazing staff you guys are the
best
i'll give you that
but you've never told you never gave
francis a fair shot we've never heard
his story
never
we had he had to go on joe rogan to hear
the whole story
rogan did that ufc didn't book france on
rogan
rogan called france's team and booked
that rogan books himself
if he saw his apology today
apology i wouldn't call an apology i
would call it a uh
an informational
video a nine minute video on instagram
from his side of things he'd say i book
it all myself yeah you'll see him book
that and that's how we got france's
story on the biggest show in the world
that's not ufc's doing
why not why not be cool man for once be
cool you guys have one man
and if you're worried about other
fighters following france's footsteps
i get that you don't want to set you
know presidents where
other every guy's doing this you're not
france is an outlier he's a once in a
[ __ ] lifetime fighter man and if you
[ __ ] him over you're gonna regret it
it's gonna be the biggest regret you've
ever had
ever
ever ever you know how historic it's
gonna be for francis for steison fury
you guys don't be involved in that
i know espn pays your nut and you guys
get all the money from them i get it man
but you guys know what's right i know
ari emanuel knows what's right too and
he's the one that made you apologize for
doing this and he's the one that when
you guys when he tells you to jump you
ask how high
ari
he's and he's not from the fight world
he's not from this world he's from the
business world and that's why he's
trying to make you make this right
figure it out guys figure it out
you got to figure it out
have to
you just have to i beg you guys again
you want to charge more money charge all
these pay-per-views put on pay-per-view
once a once a month then we gotta pay
for [ __ ] espn plus do all that stuff
i get all of it
do what's right imagine if any other
sport treated us like this treat the
fans like this
imagine if because georgia was
represented by somebody else
you wouldn't let them play in the
national championship you let them go
play elsewhere because you didn't like
the representation you didn't want to
sit in the same room as them
imagine the uproar
imagine how furious fans would be
it'd be insane
be insane
but our audience the fighter is so
custom just taking it
taking it and shutting up because we
have no control over it for the first
time
francis has all the control and you guys
can't afford to miss out on a francis
renewed contract again he's not asking
for 10 20 million
i'll make that generational money i'll
make that in the tyson fury fight
so just play ball don't get in the way
help him out
because again nobody's better at marking
nobody's better negotiation he's gonna
have to have somebody a big dog
negotiate that contract against tyson
fury
and the one shot the small chance he
knocks tyson fury out
how great does that make the ufc look
that your heavyweight champ knocked out
the best heavyweight of all time
i'll debate you all day on tyson fear
being in the heavyweight jamp all the
time by by the way the best i'll i'll
argue that all day give me who you
think's better enticing fury
skill wise defense footwork his size
yeah he's not a knockout artist but as
far as fundamentally get the [ __ ] out of
my face there's nobody better i was
smoking those old school guys you want
to talk about joe frazier muhammad ali
mike tyson riddick beau likes all the
same size don't have the same footwork
argue that all day and if francis and he
can
if he lands that [ __ ] bomb on him and
wins
what's that do for this
sport of the ufc
what if he went unsigned with bellator
or ryzen or one championship
well then they get all the accolades
also if you don't sign him and say jon
fights stephen which i think will happen
this year because france is out with the
knee
are they really the champ because the
the the guy that i know is the champ
isn't fighting so you have a fake champ
and he that's forever and beyond his
record
so there's so there's a butterfly effect
there's me some the downside to not
playing ball and being cool with francis
the downside is so much bigger than the
upside
it's not even close man
and i know you guys know this it's just
the goddamn egos in the way
unreal
that's my ranch